[Inaudible].
It's time to get one of the most divisive comedians. Adam Sandler,
a lot of critics have dismissed Sandler as the low point of modern comedy.
His films have been called juvenile amateurish, lazy and just plain awful.
After years of vicious criticism,
Sandler says he no longer even reads zoned reviews saying so I did stop
reading them. It didn't, it makes sense to me.
And it screwed my thinking up a little bit. When we were writing the next one,
me and my buddy were like, you think they're going to hate this. If we do this.
And we started saying, what's the difference? The only time Sandler gets here,
even a modicum of critical respect is when he steps out of his comfort zone and
takes on meatier roles.
But even then critics use these films as further proof of Sandler's laziness.
The implication seems to be, if he's capable of such a nuanced performances,
why has he squandered his talents in tasteless comedies?
This same pattern repeated itself just last year,
Sandler started one of his most critically acclaimed films yet uncut gems,
many even thought Sandler deserves an Academy award nomination for his
performance,
but critics still painted uncut gems as a rare exception in Sandler's career.
A brief bright spot admits his usual dumpster fires. However,
we here at wisecrack think the opposite uncut gems.
Isn't a rare exception in Sandler's filmography,
rather it's the culmination of Sandler's entire career.
That is to say Sandler's passwords. Billy Madison grownups, Mr. Deeds, and yes,
even Jack and Jill were merely covert preparation for his best role
yet. So welcome to this wisecrack edition on the genius of Adam Sandler,
spoilers ahead for uncut gems and a few classic Sandler comics. Well,
before we get into it,
I want to give a shout out to raid shadow legends for sponsoring this episode.
Raid is a massive hero RPG and is available to download on mobile and PC
collect, equip, train,
and upgrade your team of heroes to defeat bosses and earn special crisis.
The more you play,
the more you are rewarded with resources that could help maximize your team's
strength.
You can upgrade heroes by sacrificing certain smaller heroes or by making your
way through the different campaigns. The game is constantly updating.
So there was always something fun and new to do right now.
You can participate in the tag team arena competition,
which is the next level of PVP battles. In this series,
you can rate in a bracket to win special rewards.
It's a little more challenging than regular gameplay,
but that only makes it more fun rate. It's free to play.
So download it now using the links in the description.
If you use our links that are a new player, you will receive 50,000 silver,
50 jams, one energy refill, one clam Bosky five mystery shards,
one day XP booster and one free champion. The executioner,
all this treasure will be waiting for you here.
The rewards will only be available for the next 30 days. So check it out. Now.
Now let's get back to the show on the surface.
Uncut gems seems like a pretty big departure for the Sandman in the film.
Sandler stars as Howard Ratner, a diamond district jeweler,
always looking to make a quick buck this time from a glitzy Ethiopian Opal
problem is Howard's a gambling.
You take lightening beds, but you don't want any part of lightening.
Cause come on a thousand dollars a point, okay?
Yes.
Already in the hole for a hundred grand who was loan shark brother-in-law Arno.
After approximately 90 minutes of blood pressure raising shenanigans,
Howard sells the oval to NBA player. Kevin Garnett as a good luck charm,
but instead of using this cash to pay off his debts immediately,
Howard bets big on the Celtics, believing Garnett will have.
The great game. There's a bet in that bag.
I want you to take on all of it inside the bag and place it on that.
And locks are no one is goons behind Bulletproof glass in his store to watch
other game plays out.
The bet appears to pay off the Celtics win and Howard scores.
The millions he's been after, but it's too late. When he unlocks the door.
Arno's goons are so fed up by his antics.
They shoot him dead and robbed his jewelry store.
Not the typical Sandler happy ending.
[Inaudible].
If you haven't seen this film, it is very good.
Like a two hour long panic attack that you somehow remember fondly.
It's also a dark gritty drama was not a single scatological joke or pratfall to
be found. And it's two hour plus runtime yet. There's one thing.
Uncut gems shares with all of Sandler's previous films.
See throughout Sandler's career, he's cultivated one specific comedic persona,
no matter the role, be it a wealthy air or water boy,
the son of Satan or a diamond district to jeweler each Sandler character is
essentially the same and emotionally stunted Manchild in 1970 scholar
philosopher in union psychoanalysts,
Marie Louis Von Franz identified a growing trend in young men there refuse to
grow the FM.
This persona is called the pure attorneys Latin for the eternal child in her
book.
The problem of the pure attorneys Von France stated the man who identified with
the archetype of the pure attorneys remains too long and adolescent psychology.
That is all those characteristics that are normal in youth of 17 or 18 or
continued into later life.
It's worth noting that the problem of the pure attorneys came out right on the
heels of the 1960s, a decade defined by the sudden emergence of youth culture,
the youth of the 1960s rebelled against previous generations rejecting
traditional norms,
like the nine to five and mingle duties and not dropping acid,
being young and carefree became idealized in pop culture.
And people began holding onto their youth for far longer than was traditionally
acceptable. Cue the mantra, according to Von Franz,
most man children share the same basic characteristics.
They struggled to maintain long lasting jobs and are unable to find a place in
society because they refuse to adapt to social norms.
Instead they sit around and do pretty much nothing to quote Von Franz.
The pure attorneys' lives in a continual sleepy days.
The sleepy on disciplined long leg of youth who merely hangs around his mind,
wandering indiscriminately so that sometimes one feels inclined to pour a bucket
of cold water over his head.
These men are often quite arrogant to quality that stems from an inferiority
complex and false feelings of superiority.
These men are also attracted to women who can their mother who can in fold them
in her arms and satisfy their every need.
And they're prone to dangerous acts and sports because they yearn to get away
from reality from the earth from ordinary life.
Whether you accept Von Francis take on modern manhood or not,
you can probably see how Adam Sandler's early characters uniformly fit this
description.
It's important to note that Sandler isn't just a work for hire comedian.
He's also a co-writer on almost all of the work in his lower brow oeuvre. Thus,
it isn't just Sandler's acting,
but also his writing and storytelling choices that helped construct his
man-child persona take Sandler's breakthrough performance. And Billy Madison,
Billy spends all his time lounging in a pool and drinking himself into a stupor
behavior, which certainly suggest a desire to escape reality.
He has no job prospects to speak of and absolutely no desire to fit into
conventional society. The most pressing thing on Billy's mind.
Shampoo is better. I go on first and clean their hair
better. I leave their hair silky and smooth for this role.
Sandler adopts what would become one of his trademarks,
a high pitched and garbled voice as if a grown man were attempting to mimic a
child's voice.
Ooh, that wasn't very nice. This.
He realizes Billy's refusal to grow up. When people criticize Billy,
he immediately lashes out his face, brunching up in despair and anger,
like a confounded toddler about to erupt.
I hate cursive and I hate all of you.
Like the prototypical man-child Billy also has a major inferiority complex.
It's not a coincidence that his primary antagonist is Eric Gordon,
a stuck-up businessman who Lloyds his Harvard education, overbuilding.
Second team, all American Harvard tree.
I mean people Billy can relate to on any level at all our first graders,
once back in elementary school, he's in his element there.
His silly jokes aren't met within different stairs, but.
Laughter what do you think of that? Mr. Blue duck dad's quack cash. Dick.
Even Billy's romantic interest fits Von Franz is pure attorneys description
teacher.
Veronica Vaughn serves as a maternal figure to Billy helping this man-child
study and grow throughout Sandler's early films.
He consistently plays this same childlike figure of lashing out in an adult
world that doesn't know what to make of him.
In the first 10 minutes of Abby Gilmore,
happy beats up a coach who dares to mock him.
Then.
He goes home to his girlfriend, a teacher yet again,
and asked her to stay the night because he's had a rough day, just like Billy.
Happy wants a maternal figure to make everything better.
But this time the girlfriend has no interest in baby. And Sandler's man-child.
She calls happy a loser and leaves.
I am not spending the rest of my life with a loser.
Afterwards.
Happy go to the batting cage where he proceeds to let baseballs hit him directly
in the face and act Von Franz would undoubtedly label a dangerous sport.
Happy through this pain seeks to escape the reality of his failures and the only
person impressed by these immature antics.
You guessed it a child and Sandler's next film, the water boy.
He goes even playing Bobby, a juvenile man-child who still lives with his mom.
Did he tell you about a little bedtime problem? Mama banking. You don't that,
that sheet back there.
Much of the comedy and the Waterboy stems from Bobby's childlike responses to
the adult world.
Is there a girl you're seeing?
I see a lot of girls again.
Sandler emphasizes the characters,
childlike naivete adopting a baby is Lisbon stutter and slouching like an
uncomfortable kid at school and like a child Bobby legitimately struggles to
retain eye contact with anybody. However, a Sandler got older.
His depictions of the man child began to grow take 1999 big daddy.
And which Sandler stars is Sony Kofax but 32 year old slacker with no job or
prospects to speak of.
The film opens exactly like happy Gilmore with Sonny's girlfriend breaking up
with him because of his immature lifestyle.
Why are you being so nuts to me lately?
Because you refuse to move on to the next phase of your life.
Previous films,
big daddy focuses less on Sandler's immature antics and more on his maturation.
Sandler here issues.
Many of his early trademark signatures like the baby voice or child is slouch.
Instead Sandler adopts a disaffected slacker attitude as if Sony were in a
perpetual haze, watching life passing by.
But after Sony takes in an abandoned child,
he's forced to grow up and become a father figure Sandler's character,
no longer wets the bed.
Now he's the one who has to clean up the mess by the end of big daddy.
Sonny turns his life around becoming a successful lawyer with a wife and child
of his own. That's a pretty big departure from.
I got it. And then back home.
But this one.
Just the beginning of Sandler's maturation.
When the comedian reached his forties, he became a family man literally,
and on screen Sandler's films during this later period reflect his own personal
growth as a husband and father,
while presenting a more nuanced outlook on the man-child Sandler's later films
typically spotlight a former mantra move.
Now in middle-age feels weighed down by domestic responsibilities to this
Sandler character urines to return to the freedom of childhood.
That is he wants to become a man child. Once again,
the film that best encapsulates this later Sandler period outlook,
none other than the offer gotten click. Yeah, that's right.
I said it click and click Sandler stars is Michael Newman,
an overworked architect exhausted by daily life.
When Michael gets a remote that can rewind and fast forward through time,
he also gets the opportunity to sidestep all adult responsibilities and
indulgent juvenile antics. Once more in essence,
Michael gets to literally become a man-child one who can fart in his boss's face
and its consequences.
Michael can also skip past anything that's too emotionally challenging,
but by constantly fast-forwarding tasks has responsibilities.
Michael ultimately misses out on the most significant parts of his life,
neglecting his children and wife until they leave him. By the end, a tearful,
Michael has learned his lesson
Sandler's films throughout the odds consistently play out in this exact same
fashion, focusing on family,
men who yearned to return to their childhood yet who ultimately learn to embrace
their responsibilities.
Can be difficult.
Sometimes it gets bumpy with family and kids and things not
going exactly like you planned,
but that's what makes it interesting in life.
The first act always exciting. The second act,
that's where the depth comes in.
Which brings us full circle to uncut gems.
A film that shows the dark side of what happens when the man-child never quite
grows up.
Sailor brilliantly takes his trademark comedic persona and applies it to a
so-called serious film.
Howard has all the same basic characteristics of Sandler's previous man-child
rules, inferiority complex.
Oscar's the wrong. I could go out and get six appraisers right now,
five of them would say at least $3,000 a carrier.
Check a need for a maternal figure to tell him everything's going to be okay.
Even though she's at least 20 years younger than him. Oh,
you betcha prone to dangerous accidents.
Sports now is just describing the whole movie.
Howard constantly puts his life on the line for a series of increasingly risky
bets. I mean, all you have to do is take one.
Look at Howard's bachelor pad to see what a man truly is.
It's a 15 year olds dream come true,
complete with Nick's memorabilia and a portrait of a naked lady.
This has rendered all the more pathetic given that Howard's in his fifties,
what's more Howard, constantly neglects his familial duties.
His had always focused on his latest scheme.
Howard's wife literally has to chastise him into tucking his son into bed rather
than watch a basketball game that he's bet on
in the early man-child films.
Sandler could almost always rely on his family support, no matter his antics,
but in Oka gems,
Howard is rendered all the more tragic because nobody has his back. In fact,
his entire family turns against him.
I think you were the most annoying person I have ever met.
I hate being with you. I hate looking at you. And if I had my way,
I would never see you again.
Ford's daughter to stains him and at some can barely look at him after
discovering.
He has a mistress who was the girl living in your apartment and to add insult to
injury it's Howard's own brother-in-law that's hired the goons threatening to
kill him in a metal twist. It's almost as if Howard's family mirrors,
the harshest critique leveled against Sandler.
His wife is a stand in for all the critics who instinctively find the comedian
annoying on screen.
Whereas his children are a stand in for everyone who thinks Sandler's at
disappointment for wasting his talents and slumming it in juvenile comedies.
Unlike big daddy and click where Sandler's character,
see the error of their ways and eventually grow up.
Howard never does two thirds of the way through uncut gems.
He finally has a moment of clarity lamenting to his girlfriend.
[Inaudible] close to do everything I do. It's not going right.
Everything I do is not going right, but how are you?
Unlike Michael or sunny never takes a moment to learn from his mistakes.
Instead.
He doubles down on it coming up with yet another get rich quick scheme and the
results well speak for themselves.
Sandler's career may have started out by glorifying the man-child,
but as he's grown,
his perception of the persona has apparently become far darker,
culminating in uncut gems with the man-child literal death.
It's unnerving to think that all the juvenile antics, baby soda,
voices and poop jokes have led to well tragedy.
What was once labeled that dumb archetype has morphed into a Shakespearean
character flaw. Ultimately it's Howard's refusal to grow up, to change,
to learn, to engage with any semblance of reality.
That proves to be as undoing a character like Howard should be inherently
unlikeable yet because Sandler has grown up playing this character through his
entire career. He's able to inject Howard with the Patheos.
And affability only someone who knows the type like the back of his hand could,
this is the role that Sandler was born to play.
And the culmination of his man-child persona.
It's almost too fitting that the Safdie brothers spend years trying to give Sam
or to take on the role who else could have played it to such perfection.
So will Adam Sandler fulfill his destiny of starring in movies that aren't
terrible? Well, maybe not so fast in a recent interview,
Sandler joked that if he didn't get an Oscar nomination for uncut gems,
he would to quote himself and come back and do a movie again.
That is so bad on purpose just to make you all pay. That's how I get them.
Perhaps prove the man-child never quite dies after all. What do you guys think?
Does uncut gems, Mark peak, Adam Sandler, man childhood.
Where does he even go from here? Let us know what you think in the comments.
Big,
thanks to our awesome patrons for supporting us hit that subscribe button and as
always, thanks for watching later.
[Inaudible].